welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the only host
who isn't Dolores right now and this
episode were breaking down episode 5 of
Westworld we're more than halfway
through this season and with just three
episodes left after this one there's a
lot to unpack throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down the
latest entry and giving our thoughts on
what's going on in the show there will
of course be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check out
episode 5 year and don't want anything
ruined then I highly recommend that you
turn off now make sure you subscribe to
the channel because we do fan theories
and breakdowns on the show week by week
and you don't want to miss any of the
updates without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of Westworld
[Music]
[Music]
okay so episode 5 actually reminded me a
lot of the hooded justice episode of
Watchmen there's a ton of stylistic
editing choices and overall it fills in
a lot of details about one of our key
characters that is serac the episode
opens with Ciroc is a boy watching the
annihilation of Paris we learned that
his brother was there with them but he's
been omitted from history I'll go into
this more as we get into the video but
it's a very important aspect to bear in
mind as we discuss their relationship
there is a reason why we didn't see him
in the flashback last week and those who
Rock knows who he is I think the
creative team behind this show didn't
put him in the flashback of episode 4
because as we learn in the century he's
been removed from the future or at least
its path through a certain technique
that is a process called
editing now whilst he wasn't literally
removed I do appreciate that the right
is behind Wes will did sort of edit him
into the flashback this week so that we
could retrospectively see why he wasn't
there it's a nice little directorial
choice there are others here that called
back to west world in many ways we see
serac running his hand through maze at
one point and this is a call back to
when Maeve did it this imagery has
appeared throughout the show and I
believe that it symbolizes innocence
that is soon stripped away so Rach has
to do terrible things in order to save
the world much like how Maeve had to
save her people I suppose so there are a
lot of things to take from it we watch
his serac and his brother build
iterations of Rehoboam which are all
named after figures in the Hebrew Bible
as we know this machine runs an
algorithm that can predict the future
and therefore this gives serac an upper
hand when it comes to prophesizing how
to control the planet serac states that
there are things you can't predict which
are flies in the ointment we learned
throughout the entry that surak's goal
is to edit these out from the future to
stop chaos from taking over however
there may be a deeper meaning this
mention of flies could actually be a nod
to the flies that have appeared
throughout West world with them they
often symbolize a problem or bring forth
a new awakening and serac trying to
remove these could show that he wants to
end all notion of free thought and
movement we cut to his watch which has a
direct line to Rehoboam and this
cases he is always in contact with it a
fly buzzes around the person that he's
talking to but it's quickly swatted away
perhaps once more showcasing that
chaotic elements will not be tolerated
this is the president of Brazil which we
learned serac helped to get elected in
exchange for him carrying out certain
actions that would keep everything on
track
what's Iraq has done is basically create
loops for Humanity similar to what the
hosts had and these keep everyone in
line with the prison that they cannot
see touch taste or smell or matrix serac
clearly has his fingers in all of the
pies whether it's politics currency tech
or war he controls it all in order to
stop the world from spiraling downwards
he can topple governments in mere
minutes should have come down to it and
the man is the most powerful person on
the planet what's Iraq has accomplished
is that he's become the puppeteer of the
world stage he is placed certain members
of society in key positions all of whom
he has complete control over and
therefore he is the one pulling the
strings we saw this with Charlotte Hale
who Ciroc had clearly manipulated into
becoming his mole and it's clear that he
rules the world
now raha BAM does something interesting
in this episode in that it creates a
tunnel at one point which allows it to
access certain elements of the past this
sort of gives an inclination of how it
works and it ties in slightly with
another TV show called dev's which i
think does operate in a similar manner
it is likely that Rehoboam has taken all
data from before the privacy laws in
West world came into place and using
this it is predicted absolutely
everything in devs they state that there
are no such things as random events and
even things such as coin flips can be
predicted should you know the weight of
the coin the speed in which it's flipped
the height of its ascension and the
surface that it lands on everything is
predictable with the correct data and
what Rehoboam has done is that it has
collated all of this placed it into its
system to map out humanity and therefore
it can make highly accurate predictions
we look over them as they go into
business with Liam Dempsey senior the
co-founder of insight that gave serac
and his brother all of the data on
humanity it initially appears that
Rehoboam doesn't work and he pulls the
plug this is where Sir acts brother
states that they should kill him as he
will simply get in the way they view
human life is
significant should have become a hurdle
in global security and similar to how
Dempsey senior could have done this in
the past Dolores is now doing this in
the present we cut to her Caleb and
Dempsey junior and I love how they have
him in a t-shirt with basic written on
it though he has clearly lived a life in
which he's regarded as a tech for some
reason it's become crystal clear
throughout the season that he isn't and
he's probably one of those people who
rings you up to ask how it is that you
call people on their iPhone which it
which is something that's really
happened to me I love you mother after
kidnapping him Dolores reminds us that
Dempsey has been trying to outbid Ciroc
on Dallas and that the latter isn't
happy about it Doris wants access to
Rehoboam so that they can study serac
and learn his weaknesses
Dempsey uses his glasses to scan Dolores
and he sees that she's a blank slate
however when he does it to Caleb there
are hints that something far worse is
wrong with him now Caleb does talk about
putting a gun into his mouth on some
beach and though this is likely a jab at
his apparent suicide in the future it
could also be significant to his past we
do know that Caleb was shot in the head
at some point when he was in the army
and it is possible that this was at his
own hands Dempsey denies having any
involvement with sending him to war and
Caleb asks what he really saw when he
looked at him however just before we get
any answers he stabs him in the neck
with the drugs onre which the episode is
named after this hallucinogen was said
to have the ability to take you back to
the silent era and it certainly seems to
do that with the screen going black and
white we learned that it's like a movie
marathon and seeing Caleb go through key
points in film history really makes this
episode a standout now I do believe that
Dempsey doesn't have anything to do with
the death of Caleb's friend or the
excursion that caused it as like his
t-shirt says he's basic after Dolores
gets Dempsey back and they jump in a
ride a track instantly by surak's men
which leads them into a gun battle set
to ride of the valkyries this is a
callback to Apocalypse Now in which a
helicopter played it through their
loudspeakers in order to intimidate the
Vietcong it's an amazing piece of music
and here the battle plays out to all of
the crescendos of the piece also I love
the romantic music that starts a blare
as Caleb looks at Dolores gunning people
down in the
Westworld has these hilarious moments
like this from time to time and had me
cracking up watching him slowly fall in
love with his fembot there helped by
ashen giggles who we know from the reco
job in episode 1 they actually drop a
lot of lines that I had to look up such
as calling Dempsey Tom Canty which is a
character from The Prince and the pauper
by Mark Twain it also called him Lord
falton Roy which is a callback to the
novel by Frances Hodgson Burnett the
quite obscure literary references which
could highlight that the two are
extremely intelligent however they've
been placed into positions where they're
held back because the system won't allow
them till about their full potential it
is keeping everyone in a cage and
allowing them to operate as petty
criminals in order to stop them from
disrupting the greater whole so we can
take from this that Rehoboam will allow
you to do things against the law so that
you have a feeling of freedom but you're
still trapped in its cycle they have a
quick catch up and together as a group
they hop on a train now this has a lot
of subtext to it and it's the perfect
setting for the following explanation
dolores divulges that Rehoboam has
pre-written their futures metaphorically
they are on train tracks traveling from
one destination to the other unable to
divert or choose a new direction dolores
shows that she can predict their
behavior and this is similar to the
scene that happened with mabe in which
she too discovered that she was a slave
to a program it's as unnerving for them
as it was for Maeve and seeing them
discover when they'll die and so on
comes as a big gut punch it's a system
of false hope that makes humanity suffer
and they are like rats trapped in a
bucket waiting to drown
Delores unleashes this data on a train
and we get a small glimpse of what could
happen on a worldwide scale should
everything be made public I loved
reading some of the character traits
such as a man being labeled as creepy
but others like characters being removed
from the gene pool and the suicide of a
child really feel tragic and harrowing
elsewhere canals aka Dolores takes
Bernard to Rehoboam explaining how the
machine works whilst releasing the data
from it namely the info on socks brother
in the past we see that their machine
was able to predict the stock market and
this is likely how serac became the
richest man in the world
Dempsey senior is blown away by this but
eventually he becomes too greedy and so
lock him out we learned that there was
also a major problem in this system no
matter what predictions they ran the
world eventually ended and this was
because of outliers anomalies within the
program that would eventually lead to
the world stamp fall so racks brother
who I know I know his surname is serac
as well it's just easier like this
anyway sir axe brother was one of these
and therefore he was edited out or
rather sent to a re-education Center we
discover that this is called energy
Ernie's and you may recall this name
this is also where the man in black or
or rather white was sent and it is
possible that they will free not only
sir axe brother but also William in the
upcoming entries the data is unleashed
unto the whole world and the group
leaved the train has shown that they
have left the tracks that have kept them
in a prison they ascend upwards above
all those realizing that their reality
is a prison they have been broken free
of their loops and we see firsthand that
information is power
riots begin to happen we watch Kaleb go
on the escalator from episode 1 except
this time he has a brand new perspective
a variation of Space Oddity by David
Bowie beautifully plays out as things
descend into chaos and two of Sirach
shooters arrived to assassinate Kaleb
but he's saved by Dolores finally he
realizes that she isn't this real thing
and that she is a machine similar to the
very thing that they're fighting in the
past we discovered that serac
experimented on his own brother who was
running scenarios in the system that
would lead to the death of Dempsey
senior in the future we do learn that
serac did kill Dempsey senior perhaps
showing that he only house his brother
so that he could get full control of the
machine in the present canals divulges
to Bernard about the editing process and
Stubb shows up and saves him now how he
got into the facility we don't know but
serac did tell Hale that she wasn't the
only person working for him and it is
possible that he has control over Stubbs
and this is how he was able to get entry
so easily we also learn that Bernard is
irreplaceable and therefore it is
possible that he is the key to the
greater beyond serac believes that
Dolores is but it makes much more sense
for it to be Bernard and this is why
Dolores was so adamant that he had to be
brung out with her we did see that
Bernards pearl was red when Dolores was
with Hale and therefore it is possible
that this is infused with the key to the
door so racks forces arrived
in canal states that his rollers
finished just as Martel arrives to
escort him away to cease Iraq he appears
in the room as a hologram without the
need for VR glasses and it is possible
that this is the mirror world though
there is a device that shows his
hologram it is different so yeah there
is something that could be happening
here we saw our video on this theory
last week then you'll know we said that
we believe that Rehoboam has created a
mirror world which runs simulations on
all possibilities and outcomes this
would explain how the show is ramped up
so quickly and it would also mean that
everything we watched so far has been in
a false reality perhaps Iraq is just
seeing what damage Dolores could cause
should he not stop her as it feels
unlikely to me that they would have sent
the world of the brink of the apocalypse
with three episodes and a couple of
seasons remaining I have been wrong
several times but yeah I don't know I
just don't believe that this is all as
it seems
canal's blows himself up killing Martell
and the henchmen they arrive at the
beach to the theme of The Shining
and this is the same pier that caleb was
doomed to kill himself upon in the
future we see a man staring into the
ocean and also a woman jogging along the
pier which could highlight the summer
following his footsteps with the crash
of their reality here they decide what
to do with Dempsey he taunts the group
namely caleb with his past and we see
that he carried out interrogations and
was likely complicit in inhuman acts ash
shoots Dempsey to prove that she does
have a choice and she leaves with
giggles as Dempsey dies on the beach
caleb gets more flashbacks and we see at
one point that he himself was in a
region centre Dempsey's final words are
you did it and it is possible that he
perhaps committed an atrocity and was
then re-educated and put back into the
system as for how BAM no longer viewed
him as a threat maybe he is being
completely re-engineered and that is why
his mother doesn't recognize him it's
also possible that Rahab and predicted
he was a problem and therefore instead
of dealing with him they just shipped
him off the war where he would be blown
up therefore no one would really
question his disappearance and he would
still die however caleb survived his
fate and therefore he's returned as an
anomaly this could be what Dempsey Jr
was talking about earlier in the episode
when he said he wasn't the one who
shipped him off and it's
that something deeper is going on here
whatever the case his memory has been
wiped and we cease Iraq in the desert
with Dempsey senior good old Dempsey
believes that serac won't kill him
because Rehoboam didn't predict he would
however we all know that West's world is
about breaking free of loops sir
oximeter Maeve Delores and a lot of the
hosts that realized they were on
pre-program loops use this information
to break free of the system so rat kills
the character proving that you can still
have autonomy and he makes the death
look like a plane crash in the present
Dolores stands toe-to-toe with a
hologram of Sirach and she states she's
learned about his brother and that it's
time everyone woke up Caleb and Delores
jump on a plane similar to the one that
serac brought down and they head to the
re-education Center to free his brother
unlikely the man in black Caleb gets a
special delivery and this may be because
he could be the one to take out Delores
when it comes to it throughout the
episode there were discussions that
Caleb shouldn't be too trusting of her
and this ending does setup the two
perhaps going head to head down the line
so rack has likely seen every outcome
and he knows that caleb is a wild card
thus he is sent a man to give him a
weapon perhaps the thing that Caleb did
that Dempsey accused him of is put
humanity back in its cage but a guess we
will have to wait and see
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode and what you
thought of the fifth entry comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please drop a thumbs up and
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the series so far if you want to support
the channel from as little as a 99 cents
a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people us subscribe
to the channel and this month you can
win the Star Wars Skywalker saga box set
and all you have to do is comment on a
video and make sure you sub with
notifications on the more videos you
comment on the more you have a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of March in the cell be shipped
out from then to ever gets the prize
it's the best of luck to everyone who
takes part
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you